[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you are watching vega flight vv18 which
is
as of this moment one of four rockets
that were launched in 2021 by aryan
space
europe's largest and the world's first
commercial launch service provider
having a billion in revenue in 2020 and
having held at least 60 percent of the
market share for commercial launch
services in 2014
aryan space would seem like its position
in the space launch industry
could be potentially lucrative when the
space economy is teaming with potential
for growth
however this position is only a figment
an aryan space's weakening position in
the growing space sector
may actually reflect a weakening
european position
not only for the commercial launch
industry itself but also from many other
potential profitable
european space industries and companies
for the past few years
aryan space's market share has declined
and it shouldn't be a surprise
what caused it looking from this side of
the atlantic you appear to put a
bit of a frightener on europe ministers
are meeting in the next few days to
consider
upgrading or even replacing the ariane
rocket what's your view when you look
across the atlantic
arion5 has has no chance
i mean really it's i don't say that with
a sense of provider but there's really
no way for that vehicle to compete
with falcon 9 and falcon heavy um
so if i were in the position of iron i
would really push for an ariane 6. i
think that's the right move
it's about price isn't it i mean and you
have really come in
very very low can you sustain those
prices are they realistic
yes absolutely not only can we sustain
the prices
the next version of falcon 9 is actually
able to go to a lower price
so if arion can't compete with the
current falcon 9 it sure as hell can't
compete with the next one
with the advent of falcon 9 launch costs
have reduced
and following simple supply and demand
spacex's market share in the commercial
launch market
particularly for launching satellites
has risen and this can produce problems
for aryan space
and we are here to talk about the space
race of the 21st century
forget the space race between the united
states and
the soviet union a few decades back this
race
is about the market to launch satellites
into space
the market leader is the france-based
company ariane espace but
its competition is about to get a lot
tougher joining me here now is uh the
chief executive of arianespas stefan
israel
thank you very much indeed for being
with us today now just
for our viewers who may be unfamiliar
with
what it is that you do your business
model is essentially to put
satellites into space yes spacex's role
in gobbling up market share
for satellite launches is of particular
importance not only because satellite
launches play a major role
in producing contracts for launch
services harming aryan space
in the process but spacex's starlink
also stands to crowd out the satellite
industry
spacex is currently releasing low earth
orbit satellites
which can provide good broadband
connection for areas that don't have
easily accessible wi-fi
and this can be an extremely lucrative
industry having the potential to read
billions for spacex each year
morgan stanley one of the world's
largest investment banks estimated that
satellite broadband
will represent around 50 of the
projected growth of the global space
economy by 2040
an industry that could generate more
than one trillion dollars in revenue
if a foothold is lost in the satellite
broadband industry this could be
potentially dangerous for european
growth
if scale and vertical integration works
like economics teaches us that it will
spacex further embedding itself
and the satellite production chain will
only drive down its costs
which will inevitably drive demand
because of lower prices although europe
is known for space independence
particularly with copernicus and galileo
europe is simply behind
in terms of capital investment into
space ventures which would give europe a
greater chance
for reaping the benefits of a growing
space economy the eib
the european investment bank has found
that many european companies
trying to invest and begin something in
space are often finding difficulty
in getting venture capital funding
within europe and this can result in
space entrepreneurs
looking for private capital outside of
the eu although this may be a further
stretch to make
it represents a problem of keeping
european companies connected with the
land they come from
with many innovative european companies
or founders
especially in the tech sector getting
acquired by u.s rivals
and as a result acquired away from
europe grabbing onto space growth
is beneficial because it means
employment more tax revenue
and positive feedback loops for further
investment
being in a top position in the new space
race is undeniably lucrative
and europe must keep up with the
industry if it wants to reap the
benefits
of this growth it's also important to
understand that even if launch costs may
be reduced by spacex
it wouldn't be fair to argue that europe
will completely lose its position
it's not as though the european space
agency will suddenly abandon air in
space for launches
and focus primarily on cheaper
commercial space companies in other
countries
a european route to space will still
exist be it lucrative or not
however just because european space
organizations will stay besides other
european space organizations
this does not mean that europe's
autonomy in space will remain constant
multiple countries are investing in
defense technologies based in space
and many of them have interests that are
deeply at odds with european values
although losing on the broadband
industry mentioned before could cause a
loss in autonomy in itself
particularly for economic growth
autonomy and space can be measured
through other developments
access to european satellites is beyond
the value they provide to an economy
but it's also the assets they produce
that provide value in the first place
satellites can provide access to
tremendous amounts of data information
on the environment
communication tools and necessary
information on eu security
having mainly external broadband
satellite infrastructure outside of
europe
would be the same as having all data
centers clustered outside as well which
would produce a reliancy external to
europe's borders
which is safe to say not something that
europeans who want solidarity and
autonomy
within their borders will likely want
however
the european union is taking steps to
keep up
with large pushes by chiripiton the
commissioner for the eu eternal market
and also whose responsibility is
maintaining the eu's autonomy in space
there's been a push for more eu
solidarity in space and the european
union in april 2021
approved the adoption for the eu space
program setting in motion the largest
european budget for space ever
14.88 billion euros encompassing eu
space activities alone
also the esa has invested in research
for testing full-stage reusable rockets
which may make europe's launch industry
stay competitive if it can be done fast
enough
however the united states still invests
magnitudes more in government-funded
budgets and contracts
alongside space sector finance through
venture capital although europe is doing
the right thing to remain relevant in
the space age
it may need to do more if it wants to
stay on top